foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
until we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the Dragon update video in this
video let's have a look at HBO's photos
which feature brand new scenes from
House of the Dragon season 1 episode 3.
all of these new photos show us exactly
what will happen in the next episode
this Sunday in this first New Image we
once again see viserys Targaryen holding
his firstborn son aegon the name of this
episode is actually the second of his
name a direct reference to viserys and
Allison's son aegon who is seen here as
I've said before now that viserys
finally has a male Heir almost everyone
will be wanting him to name aegon as his
new successor rather than his daughter
rhaenyra there will be some who won
aegon on the Iron Throne while there
will be many others who still want to
see rhaenyra sit on the Iron Throne like
her father wanted as you can imagine
this will divide Westeros as everyone
begins to draw their Line in the Sand
leading to an all-out War over who
should be seated on the Iron Throne now
if you look at Allison who is also
standing here in the photo you can see
she has another baby inside of her that
baby will be their daughter Helena
Targaryen once again we see Alison
Hightower standing here as she holds her
belly this is most likely in King's
Landing before they leave for the Royal
hunt in the next photo we see rhaenyra
while she's having a discussion with the
first Lannister we've seen in House of
the Dragon thus far I believe this will
be sir Tylan Lannister a knight from
House Lannister who eventually serves on
viserys Targaryen small Council as his
master of ships now make sure you're
familiar with the name and face you
should be seeing more of him from here
on out in the following photo we see him
again holding a weapon in front of
viserys Targaryen it looks like he's
giving him this as a gift this is
something we will see viserys holding
during the Royal hunt they've already
shown him stabbing at some animal in the
trailer since we haven't met the man yet
maybe this is when viserys will bring
him into his Services here again we see
rhaenyra riding off on her horse this is
where her father has set up camp for
their massive Royal hunt out in the
woods as you can see visares his family
right in style we then see rhaenyra
answer Kristen Cole in the woods now if
you remember rhaenyra selected sir
Kristen Cohen the last episode to join
her father's kingsguard
[Music]
be welcome so Kristen
you saw combat in the stormlands
Cornish March is Princess
it looks like this will be the beginning
of a new relationship with that being
said I wouldn't expect things to get hot
and steamy right out of the gate sir
Kristen Cole must remember his vows and
think what the head above his shoulders
we then see rhaenyra again reading
something about westerosi history most
likely this might be in King's Landing
when she's underneath the werewood now
we see viserys and Allison roasting
marshmallows in front of a massive fire
they might be discussing their sun and
the future of Westeros now that aegon's
here viserys will have a lot to think
about and consider like we've heard
before the whole realm is watching him
now we see viserys and rhaenyra inside
of his Royal campsite if you've seen the
episode 3 trailer then you know there
will be a scene where viserys screams in
her face
you will be with your own child sooner
than late I do not wish to get married
even I do not exist about tradition and
Duty Runner
in that scene we heard rhaenyra say she
doesn't want to get married but viserys
essentially says she doesn't have that
option even he had to do what he thought
was right for the realm it looks like
that scene was shot right here they're
wearing the exact same outfits I think
this is when we will see rhaenyra run
off on her horse into the woods forcing
sir Kristen Cole to go after her now
that aegon's here rhaenyra's entire life
is about to be flipped upside down not
only will she be set aside for another
but now she will have to do her Duty and
get married to a man she doesn't even
love next we see viserys and Serato
sitting inside of their makeshift throne
room at the Royal campsite now I want to
go to the war for the stepstones in this
incredible looking image we see Lord
Corliss valerion rushing off into battle
I must say his armor in helmet look
amazing as you all know Laura Corliss
valerion and Damon Targaryen have went
to the stepstones to defeat the crab
feeder and free up the shipping lanes
for the narrow scene
were both men who have had to cut our
own way through the world
we've been passed over
too often
in some of those other photos we can see
Laura Corliss valerion has brought some
of his family as well here we have his
son Lenor valerion this will be the same
man viserys once rhaenira to Mary we
have seen them walking along driftmark
in other photos
as you can see Lenor has joined his
father and Damon for the battle now for
those of you who don't know Lenor
valerion is a dragon rider as well the
name of his dragon is sea smoke we
should see him flying on his Dragon
alongside Daemon in caraxus in this
photo we see Damon with a letter in his
hand that letter is most likely from his
brother viserys right over Damon
shoulder is Lenor valerion once again
but the other man standing there is
vemon valerion brother of lorcoreless
valerion it looks like they're all
setting up sharp and deciding how they
will attack the crab feeder and his men
it looks like they're having some sort
of disagreements over how the battle
should be handled these men obviously do
not look happy with one another it looks
like all of these photos are from the
same scene except for this last one
right here once again we have vaimon
valerion during the heat of the battle
it looks like they stormed the beaches
where many other crab feeders men have
already fallen you can also see the
stakes behind them where we saw the crab
feeder nailing down his enemies before
the water Rose this should make for one
hell of a battle involving thousands of
men and several dragons like I said
before in my other videos it's
incredible how we're already getting a
battle this early in the first season we
never saw any battles during the first
season of Game of Thrones this is the
benefit of having a massive budget right
out of the gate they don't have to hold
back on anything like they did during
the early days of Game of Thrones House
of the Dragon is able to deliver its
fastball right away making for an
amazing first season I know I'm looking
forward to seeing how all of this will
unfold on the stepstones hopefully
Miguel was able to bring some of that
same magic he brought to Heart home and
the battle of the bastards we shall see
soon enough on this Sunday when episode
3 airs on HBO and HBO Max as always is
make sure you subscribe so you're the
first to know whenever I release a new
video there will be so many more heading
your way now before I go I want to thank
all of you for watching another video I
hope you all have a great day I'll see
you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign